>>> TONIGHT'S THE NIGHT.
JUST THE TWO OF YOU.
NO PHONES, NO E-MAILS.
JUST YOU AND THE ONE YOU LOVE.
TIME TO TUNE OUT THE WORLD AND
TUNE INTO EACH OTHER.
YOU EARNED THIS MOMENT AND
NOTHING IS GOING TO GET IN YOUR
WAY.
UNLESS YOU OWN A DOG.
>> THE DOG IS WATCHING US.
>> TO YOUR CRATE.
>> GO TO YOUR CRATE.
>> STOP.
HE THINKS YOU'RE ATTACKING ME.
>> JUST PUT HIM IN THE LAUNDRY
ROOM.
>> WITH HIS ANXIETY?
YEAH, RIGHT.
>> WE'RE JUST TALKING, LADYBUG.
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
>> GO IN THE HALL, WE'LL BE
THREE MINUTES.
>> THREE MINUTES?
>> DON'T LET YOUR FUR BABY RUIN
THE INTIMATE MOMENT YOU WAITED
FOR ALL WEEK.
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO WITH
"POUND PUPPY."
THE FURRY DOG COSTUME BIG ENOUGH
FOR TWO PEOPLE TO HAVE SEX IN.
ONCE INSIDE, YOU CAN GO TO TOWN
AND YOUR DOG WILL JUST THINK
THERE IS A MUCH LARGER DOG IN
THE ROOM.
WITH "POUND PUPPY" YOU GET THE
PRIVACY YOU NEED AND YOUR DOG
HAS A NEW BEST FRIEND.
SUITABLE FOR ANY STYLE OF
LOVEMAKING.
NEED TO CHECK ON YOUR DOG?
JUST USE THE MASCOT STYLE EYES.
>> HE'S BUYING IT.
I THINK IT'S WORKING A LITTLE
BIT TOO WELL.
>> THROW YOUR DOG AND YOURSELF A
BONE WITH "POUND PUPPY."
YOUR DOG WILL SMILE WHILE YOU
DOGGY STYLE.
AVAILABLE IN THE ADULT SECTION
OF PETCO.